In war, the enemy is clear.
But in life, in business,
that's so easy to identify. Any tips?
Well, um, I mean first of all,
that is not a true statement. And in,
in war, the enemy is not always
clear, not at all. The enemy,
the enemy can be hard to identify,
very hard to identify the enemies gonna
use camouflage to conceal themselves.
They're going to use deception to,
to distract your attention.
They're going to blend in
with the friendly civilian
populous and they're going
to take advantage of
your benevolence, right?
In fact, the enemy is going to do
absolutely everything in its power
to obscure their position,
to hide their purpose,
to even mask their identity.
So it is not easy to identify the enemy
in combat in war.
So what you have to do is you have to
control what you can control, right?
You got to be prepared. You've
got to train, you've got to study,
you've got to rehearse.
You've got to remain vigilant.
You've got to maintain discipline in
everything you do so that when the enemy
does reveal itself,
you have the ability to out
think it to out maneuver,
to out fight the enemy.
And it's actually the same
thing in business, right?
The enemy can be hard to identify.
Your competitors are
broadcasting their next move.
You don't know what the
market's going to do.
You can't be certain about the next
trend or the next downturn or the next
bubble that's gonna burst.
You can't know those things.
So you have to do the same thing. You
have to control what you can control,
which is you got to gather intelligence,
you gotta analyze the
metrics that you can track.
You've got to train yourself and your
team to be prepared for both the known and
also be prepared for the unknown.
Okay?
Figure out what the likely
contingencies are and have some plans
to execute if those contingencies occur.
Maintain discipline as an organization
so that you have the flexibility and the
responsiveness to maneuver effectively
and efficiently when the unpredictable
actually happens.
So instead of suffering and
falling apart in the chaos,
you can take advantage of it and win
and that's business and life is the same.
The enemy is not always clear in life.
It can be hard to tell who's
going to try and bring you down
or what is going to bring you
down. There's distractions,
okay?
There are things out there
that will do you harm,
that are so camouflaged.
You can't see them at all.
There are deceitful people.
There are accidents that can occur and
diseases that take root and there's bad
luck and there's Murphy's law and there's
times when it seems that the whole
world is against you.
The whole world is the enemy.
[inaudible]
and the same rules apply.
Control what you can't
control. You train hard,
learn,
maintain the mitigated daily
discipline in all things.
Yeah, train hard physically and mentally.
Push yourself so hard that you become
accustomed to the stress you get used to
it
every day.
Make yourself stronger and faster and
smarter and better so that when the enemy
does finally climb out of the
shadows and expose himself to you,
you are ready. You are waiting
and you can relish in the opportunity
to attack and fight and utterly decimate
and destroy him.